- I mentioned, you won
a Grammy for your work
with your girlfriend, Taylor Swift.
(audience cheers)
So that's amazing.
- Thank you.
- But I love that you,
I find it really cool
You did it under a pseudonym.
You, it, wasn't your name.
- Yeah.
- Why did you choose to do that?
- Well, I chose, we chose
to do it so that people
first and foremost would
listen to the music first
before dissecting the fact
that we did it together.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But um, yeah it did it
under a name William Bowery.
- Yeah
- Which sounds like
- Very fancy
- Very fancy. Sounds like a kind of
Agatha Christie character
should be wearing a monocle
with a big mustache, but it was
yeah, it was a combination
of William who my
great grandfather who I
never actually met was
a composer. He wrote a
lot of classical music
and he wrote a lot of film scores.
And then Bowery is the area
in New York that I spent a lot
of time in when I first
went over there. So..
- [Kelly] I love that.
- Stick them together.
- [Kelly] That's how you do, okay.